all right if you promoted something the
medical and political bureaucracy deemed
to be vax misinformation okay you know
what happened you instantly became a
pariah I did right so you didn't get the
shot well sometimes that got you fired
but if you converted with a known sex
criminal like Jeffrey Epstein well you
can still go on and do great things a
shocking expose in the Wall Street
Journal revealed the names of some very
prominent figures on Epstein's private
calendar meeting scheduled after his
first prison stint first up the current
CIA director William Burns he had three
meetings scheduled with Epstein in 2014
when he was deputy secretary of state
Burns even visited Epstein's townhouse
in New York City then there's Carolyn
rumler who is the former White House
counsel for Obama she had dozens of
meetings with Epstein after she left the
administration now Epstein also planned
for roomler to be on a 2015 trip to
Paris and a 2017 visit to his private
island in the Caribbean here now is
Molly Hemingway editor-in-chief of the
Federalist Fox News contributor now
Molly if you knew somebody who walked
through the capitol
um just you know not doing anything just
walk through the capitol on January 6
because you thought it was open you
probably could never ever consort with
that person again and not be dragged
through the mud but apparently there's
an exception here for Jeffrey Epstein
it's what's so amazing not just that
this information is out but how long it
has taken for this information to get
out you know this man there's so much
confusion people have in America how was
this man Jeffrey Epstein allowed to do
what he was doing how did he make his
money how did he keep his money why did
he have so many high-profile friends why
were they so powerful why was he
protected and we're getting little
Snippets of information and the
information is absolutely explosive like
you say Catherine rummler known as
Obama's fixer you know top Goldman Sachs
lawyer having dozens of meetings with
this person the current CIA head you
know and the CIA comes out and says oh
he was just asking for information about
the financial services sector that's
very implausible and Americans have
every right to know what is going on
here and they're just not getting the
information that they need
well Molly remember a lot of people had
a pretty good sense about who
um Harvey Weinstein really was and what
he was up to and again he was a mover
and Shaker in politics so they let that
all slide and it happened for years and
years with him now many of the people on
that calendar you know told the journal
that the meetings were you know for
reasons related to his money and
connections and and people said look he
we thought he rehabilitated himself
um and look Molly the benefit of the
doubt I understand that and and I get
that but the private life though was it
very private
well and not just that we clearly do
have these two standards of Justice like
you're saying if you are within a mile
of the capital and you're a grandmother
you know you're going to be spending
time in prison if you are the CIA
director and you're meeting with Epstein
the media don't even ask questions I
mean at the very least you might expect
some really big deeper Dives then five
years after his mysterious death finding
out this type of thing there hasn't been
that type of pressure or hysteria that
you associate with the media interest in
other situations you bet if it was a
Republican and anything like this it
would have been a crazy beating down the
doors Molly thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else